les premiers chiffres sont tombés
alcatel lucent va supprimer 9 134 postes
dans tout l'hexagone
le site de vélizy et le plus fortement
touché avec une suppression de 3 162
emplois ici il s'agit principalement de
métiers de support et de commerce
ce qu'on nous explique c'est que en
réduisant les commerciaux bah on va
avoir moins de possibilités de trouver
des contrats comme on aura moins de
contrats on aura moins de chiffre
d'affaires et on va encore nous dire bah
écoutez il ya moins de chiffre
d'affaires pour encore réduire les
emplois
ça représente plus de 17% des effectifs
du site qui doivent disparaître
d'après la direction pour le moment il
faut mettre en place une période de
volontariat qui va s'étaler sur deux
mois mais sur deux mois à partir de la
fin de la procédure qui démarre juste
aujourd'hui donc on pense le ca est sûre
de la période 2 avril mai juin on sait
pas exactement quand vous pour les gens
seront d'élèves confident et voilà vous
avez été démis m les critères sociaux ou
une partie de thèmes etc et vous avez
peut-être conditions vous êtes licencié
au revoir autre coup de massue pour les
salariés d'alcatel la confirmation de la
fermeture du site de vélizy
les employés se verrait délocaliser dans
l'essonne sur le site de nozay c'est ici
qu'en démarrer l'histoire quasiment
d'alcatel en france et des
télécommunications modernes la
téléphonie sans fil a démarré ici à
vélizy et le faire mais c'est vraiment
un signe très fort à la france à nos
clients et au bout pour les syndicats
l'heure est au rassemblement
c'est vrai on sent un appel à la grève
nous non pêchés pas les champs de
rentrée on empêchait pas les gens de
venir travailler mais qu'on voulait
quand même qu ils soient avec nous parce
que nous on a encore des idées d'actions
derrière est vraiment sans les salariés
on peut pas bien en début d'après midi
les salariés de vélizy ont envahi la
réunion du comité central d'entreprise
qui a dû être interrompue prochaine
action de mobilisation jeudi 6 décembre
au siège social d'alcatel lucent à paris